[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans preuve par 3
et bonne année à tous une année que nous
avons décidé de commencer dans le
plaisir et la philosophie pour vous
donner l'énergie d'affronter les défis
de 2011 notre invité c'est michel onfray
philosophe
bonsoir bonsoir merci d'être sur le
plateau de public sénat alors on vous
décrit souvent comme chantre de
l'athéisme et de l'hédonisme
vous avez créé les université populaire
de caen pour démocratiser la philo l'an
dernier vous avez fait sensation avec
votre ouvrage le crépuscule d'une idole
ou vous dézinguer freud dans un quart
d'heure nicolas truong qui est
journaliste au monde nous rejoindra sur
ce plateau pour débattre avec vous de
quelques-unes de vos thèses puis un face
à face inédit avec un grand patron de la
distribution les super et hypermarchés
que vous ne ménagez pas non plus alors
c'est serge papin qui rejoindra il est
le pdg de système u et tout de suite on
va développer avec vous à se rendre deux
points d'actualité et voir ce qui va
votre regard un peu sur ce qui va
marquer cette année d'abord puisqu'on
parle et d'athéisme il ya beaucoup
d'inquiétudes avec les menaces qui
pèsent sur les chrétiens d'orient en ce
moment après l'attentât dans une église
copte à alexandrie en egypte la semaine
dernière des menaces formulées par le
djihad islamique 100 parlementaires
français ont récemment lancé un appel
pour que la france défendent les
chrétiens d'orient et défendent le droit
de toutes les minorités à pratiquer
librement leur religion
est ce que vous pourriez signé ce genre
de texte devant demain c'est à dire que
l'athéisme n'est pas ce qu'on dit tu
sais pas parce qu'on ne croit pas en
dieu que pour autant on voudrait
interdire ceux qui croient en dieu d'y
croire
donc j'étais il ya trois semaines au
caire justement où j'ai rencontré des
coptes on a parlé de cette question des
problèmes d'unique d'une
une religion minoritaire dans un pays
parce que c'est la question qui se pose
moi je défends les minoritaires donc je
défends les minorités quand l'église a
été catholique apostolique et romaine a
été majoritaire je défende elle est
minoritaire
quand l'église est minoritaire je
défends bien sûr qu'il faut que les gens
aient le droit de s'exprimer de priés de
se rencontrer et y compris dans un pays
où ce n'est pas là lorsqu'on a réalisé
le menacer ça vaut la peine de la
défendre au nom de nos intolérances les
enchères pour le débat d'idées la
possibilité pour chacun de défendre ses
positions après le les bleus débat est
libre moi je suis athée donc je pense
effectivement qu'il ne vaut mieux aucune
religion mais tant qu'à faire je ne
pense pas qu'on puisse interdire les
religions qu'on doive les interdits de
jeu quand son contrat qu'il faut les
combattre dans la logique de la
révolution française des lumières du
débat d'idées du dialogue de de la
persuasion mutuelle et toutes religions
ne mène pas forcément à l'intégrisme
non je ne dis pas que les et des
religions mène à l'intégrisme dit qu
elle qu elles fâchent tout avec le monde
ici bas
c'est ça qui fait qu elle m'ennuie se
dire qu'il me dise ce monde ci n'a de
sens que parce qu'il ya un autre monde
qui leur donne sens le ciel l'eau de
l'ain une espèce de monde dans lequel il
y aurait des anges dieu des divinités
dessin ou je ne sais quoi et jeudi mais
il n'y a qu'une vie n'y a que ce monde
c'est arrière-monde portée d expression
est une fiction c'est ça qui me fâche
avec les religions dont 20 ans peut dire
qu'en occident on est assis sur votre
ligne finalement on a dépassé cette idée
qu'il faille attendre le monde de demain
pour trouver une forme de salut c'est
plutôt aujourd'hui justement en orient
ou dans les pays où se développent
l'intégrisme islamique que on serait
encore sur cette conception du religieux
oui vous avez raison le problème de
l'intégrisme n'est pas occidental a
priori ça ne vient pas de l'occident
encore que il faudrait s'entendre sur
ces définitions là que je pense
effectivement qu'il y ait des états
voyous des états terroristes qui lie à
ddd puissance extrêmement fortes sur la
planète qui effectivement sont des
puissances terroristes sont pas les
puissances sont pas les talibans au fin
fond de l'afghanistan qui pose problème
mais on n'a pas à les attaquer le
pakistan qui dispose de la bombe
atomique ou l'arabie saoudite donc
effectivement il ya des erreurs de
géostratégie
mais il faut savoir effectivement qu'en
europe il ya des problèmes qui ne sont
pas ceux de l'intégrisme d euros permet
de gens qui veulent importer
l'intégrisme en europe
42% des français voient l'islam comme
une menace dans un sondage ifop qui
vient de paraître
deux français sur trois pensent que
l'intégration des musulmans en france ne
s'est pas bien fait est ce que ce sont
des choses qui vous inquiète
je ne sais pas si le problème est et
dans l'inquiétude il est dans le fait
qu'effectivement on commence à avancer
au delà des lieux communs qui consiste à
dire que l'islam est une religion de
paix de tolérance et d'amour ça ce sont
les lieu commun qui sont répétées ad
nauseam si on commence à dire qu'il ya
dans le coran des des idées indéfendable
du genre misogynie phallocratie
homophobie antisémitisme éloge de la
violence de la brutalité célébration de
la guerre etc
on se fait prendre pour un islamophobe
comme sale affaire est réglée on peut
pas ne pas penser de cette question là
l'idée qu' effectivement les gens ne
soient pas ne soient pas soumis à
l'idéologie dominante l'idéologie
médiatique à l'idéologie
l'intellectuel dominante c'est plutôt
bon signe je pense effectivement qu'il
ya des gens qui conçoivent que il ya des
menaces avec l'intégrisme que
effectivement n'a pas fait la révolution
française pour que les femmes se voilent
on n'a pas travaillé à l'égalité des
juifs et des non-juifs des sommes des
esclaves des citoyens actifs ou passifs
pour utiliser l'expression d'époque pour
qu'aujourd'hui on se retrouve avec une
société inégalitaire avec des gens qui
seraient supérieures à d'autres avec la
possibilité d'égorger quelqu'un
simplement parce qu'ils ne pensent pas
comme vous mais s'avoue l'attribué à
l'essence même de certains passages du
coran ou de l'islam va écouter des
choses sont claires c'est dans le coran
moi j'ai lu le coran j'ai lu des hadiths
du prophète j'ai lu une biographie de
mahomet et les choses sont très claires
je tiens à jour des fiches très précise
et j'ai effectivement des fiches
antisémitisme homophobie sexisme loges
des célébrations de la guerre le coran
un peu dangereux de la bible je pense
que tout dépend du prélèvement dire si
vous prélevez un certain nombre de
phrases qui sont des phrases de les
rentrer dans le coran il existe aussi
des contraintes en matière de religion
d'une sourate pas de contraintes en
matière de religion
si effectivement on considère que c'est
la sourate nageurs autour de laquelle on
construit son propre islam
alors moi je défends l'islam bien sûr
mais il ya aussi dans l'islam l' inverse
disons que la bible les complexes parce
qu'elle est fabriquée de livres divers
et multiples avec des auteurs multiples
avec des gens qui ont démarré à texte si
on prend aussi un nouveau testament 8ème
9ème siècle avant jésus-christ et puis
d'autres qui sont tardives c'est-à-dire
en gros sur fait presque dix siècles sur
un millénaire la bible s'étalent avec
des auteurs différents avec des langues
différentes et aidera le coran c'est un
texte avec un auteur allons vite un peu
gabriel qui dicta à mahomet le prophète
un texte qui reste un texte univoque
dire d'une seule voix maintenant
effectivement tout et le tout tout tout
tout dépend de la présentation qu'on en
ferait pas ce que vous avez fait les
musulmans des gens qui font une lecture
extrêmement mesure est ouverte du coran
je pense à malek chebel de gens comme ça
oui mais malek chebel je sais bien il
parle d'un islam des lumières mais
oui mais ma femme et lumière s'éteint
c'est à dire si vous dit le coran est un
texte révélée c'est à dire que tout est
dit par dieu la moindre virgule le
moindre point si vous dites oui mais ça
c'est daté historiquement donc
l'interdiction de l'alcool finalement ça
vaut pas on laisse de côté on peut être
musulman et boire de l'alcool d'accord
je viens l'homophobie ces dates et
maintenant et ses terrains il faut
l'antisémitisme cette date et qu'est ce
qui va vous restez dans ce texte
pourquoi est ce qu'on se dit encore
musulmans dans ces cas là donc quand on
dit islam des lumières pourquoi pas les
lignes les lumières sans l'islam
si ici on se dit on se réclame d'un
texte qui par définition n'est pas un
texte des lumières suffit de le lire
donc je n'avais pas d'un tulle
d'indulgence pour l'islam j'ai pas
d'indulgence pour les religions on tombe
bien c'est à dire qu'il n'est pas
question pour moi de faire une espèce de
classement en disant vérité du
christianisme erreur de l'islam
reprenons le reprenons les vieilles
guerres et qui ont été les guerres des
croisades n'ont surtout pas à jeudi le
judaïsme l'islam et le christianisme me
font le même effet les trois religions
du livre sont pareillement intolérante
le christianisme a cessé d'être
intolérant parce qu'il a plus les moyens
de l'être sinon quand il peut l'être il
est tout de même faut pas oublier alors
l'actualité aussi c'est tout autre chose
le parisien qui titrait ce matin les
chinois nouveau banquier du monde qui se
disent prêts à racheter une partie de la
dette de l'espagne
est ce qu'il y à un basculement vers
l'asie qui traduirait déclin de
l'occident dont on entend souvent parler
mais moi je pense que l'europe est morte
c'est bien parce que l'europe est morte
qu'on essaie de la faire c'est à dire il
ya une espèce d'obsession à fabriquer
une europe avec une monnaie unique dont
on voit les limites d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui moi je n'ai jamais été
partisan de l'europe libérale c'est un
grand mouvement d'ex je suis un européen
convaincu mais pas cette europe libérale
dont on nous dit qu'elle devrait être
l'europe d'un grand marché si on veut
aller vite je pense que le rappel elle
voit le jour avec la conversion de
constantin ivème siècle après jésus
christ je pense que l'europe elle
commence à décliner à partir du moment
où il ya la renaissance où il ya la
pensée laïque qu elle en prend un coup
avec la révolution française
et puis que la révolution industrielle
ce qui se passe de déclin c'est une
civilisation qui ait eu lieu et elle a
vécu mille ans mais sans honneur sur
l'année là pourquoi dit elle
l'ue devra comme un romain du bas-empire
c'est à dire regardez le chef de l'état
regarder les failli coûter des
informations et vous verrez ça ressemble
étrangement au portrait qu'un certain
nombre je pensais que j bonne par
exemple de description qu'on veut plus
être faite de la décadence de l'empiré
romain on est dans une espèce de
barbarie c'est comme le titanic qui
voulait le bateau coule et il faut jouer
de la musique sur le pont pendant avec
un coup en grès démocratique
considérable en même temps pour que la
construction européenne vient couronner
avec une robe de paix depuis 50 ans je
suis pas sûr qu'il y ait un progrès
démocratique et l'illusion du progrès
démocratique mais une espèce de chape de
plomb il faut penser un certain nombre
de choses les mêmes toujours on partage
une espèce d'idéal le espèce de biparti
bipartisme français fait qu'il faut un
libéral en gros libéral de droite
libéral de gauche et que on peut
escompter arrivé au pouvoir dans ces cas
là si vous n'êtes pas libéral si vous
êtes dans les marges de cette espèce de
politiquement correct vous n'existez pas
donc vous n'avez pas de journaux pour
vous défendre ou peu de journaux quand
vous invite à ses peut vous avez 1 c'est
peu assez peu d'intellectuels
médiatiques qui sont sur ses positions
là et puis il ya une espèce de bouillie
infâme qui est donnée internet les
journaux la presse écrite la perana
presse parle etc pour lesquels on nous
dit voilà ce qu'il faut penser
démocratie pas bien sûr je pense pas que
la démocratie se soit la possibilité
d'entendre toujours les mêmes pas donné
les noms mais vous avez des
intellectuels qui donne des leçons en
permanence et il nous explique pourquoi
l'europe c'est bien pourquoi l'euro
c'est bien pourquoi le traité de réforme
constitutionnelle était très bien et
puis qui après vont vous expliquer
pourquoi les choses continuent à être
bonnes pour quoi la mondialisation est
heureuse enfin ce genre de choses je ne
crois pas que ce serait la démocratie en
2012 vous vous sentirez proche de jean
luc mélenchon si les candidats plus
proches que vous n'habitez pas si vous
êtes sans bout de bleu qui l'éloigné
d'olivier besancenot
oui oui parce qu'olivier besancenot même
intéressés quand il l'a fait savoir
qu'il est ce qu'il souhaitait unir les
gauche antilibérale dans une perspective
poste trotskiste la ligue communiste
révolutionnaire disparaissait au profit
d'un parti dont on ne savait rien
aujourd'hui qui s'appelle le nouveau
parti anticapitaliste et cette idée de
dire trouvons une gauche qui soit
antilibérale et qui soit surtout unis
moi ça m'a intéressé
jusqu'à ce que je découvre que c'était
une stratégie de communication stratégie
médiatique que c'était une façon de
reprendre une vieille façade de garder
le même magasin pour y vendre à peu près
les mêmes articles et quand j'ai
découvert qu'olivier besancenot ne
voulait pas de l'union
mon cas chaque fois qu'elles étaient
proposés finalement il a refusé je me
suis dit moi j'ai jamais été trotskiste
et pas question pour moi de continuer à
soutenir olivier besancenot
de fait quand j'ai vu apparaître jean
luc mélenchon sur la scène politique je
trouve que son discours me plaît il est
cohérent il est pragmatique il est
concret je pense que quand vous
soutiendrez si l'idée en 2012
vous pensez que soutire déjà ces
intellectuels et la 3e une paire effet
d'un mégaphone son symbole ça me paraît
un peu clair qu'on a laissé le monopole
de la parole
mélenchon c'est autre chose qu'est ce
que vous pensez de la sortie récente de
votre collègue luc ferry philosophe
aussi dix ans qui préfère marine le pen
à olivier besancenot
parce qu'il dit elle joue le jeu
démocratique et républicain ce qui ne
serait pas le cas de besancenot qui lui
est contre les élections c'est votre cas
si j'ignorais j'ignorais cette
information aujourd'hui moi je pense que
marine le pen vise une espèce de
respectabilité pour le front national
afin de pouvoir proposer des ministres
dans un gouvernement qui pourrait être
sarkozyste je pense que l est
elle est à l'ump ce que le pcf a été au
parti socialiste de l'époque de l'union
de la gauche et qu'il ya cette espèce de
désir de respectabilité
il ya quand même un volant de 15 ans 20%
chez marine le pen comment est ce qu'on
gagne des élections quand on est à l'ump
sans ça donc soit on essaie de voler les
idées de le pen ce qu'a fait sarkozy on
voit que ça ne marche pas soit
clairement fait on fait tomber un tabou
en dix ans le père était infréquentable
la fille il est un petit peu plus et
quelques postes en lui donne ne sais pas
quoi un ministère des transports et puis
et puis on fait une espèce d'union et la
gauche va être 25 ans ne pas revenir
je pensais que c'était une stratégie
d'information que vous me donnez laisse
croire qu' effectivement des philosophes
à droite qui ne sont pas contre cette
perspective du business grâce giron
d'une vaste union il suffit de lire les
textes de luc ferry dans le final de
figure on voit bien effectivement une
espèce de stratégie d' les droites qui
ont envie derrière ça la possibilité
pour la droite de s'ouvrir un front
national new look oui puisque le
les élections fonctionne comme vous
savez il ya un poids politique il faut
se trouver
vous êtes les avoir quelqu'un comme les
ferries aller dans un sens très bien au
contraire que les gens sortent du bois
et qu'on finisse par voir leurs têtes
véritable un dernier mot que vous pensez
du succès du livre de stéphane hessel
indignez-vous ses 1 500 mille
exemplaires et côté je les lui le titre
est bon le texte aussi j'veux dire quand
on voit un quand on voit ces reproches
de dire au fond des choses assez banal
basta c'est vrai les cantonne quand on
lit par ailleurs quand libération fait
trois ou quatre grandes pages de là
dessus et que la conclusion est vive
martine aubry on se dit tout ça pour ça
c'est quand même beaucoup de bruit pour
rien donc oui moi je suis pour
l'engagement je suis pour que le
programme de la résistance cnr devienne
quelque chose d'une activité d'une
vérité
importante de tout ce que le cnr avait
prévu sur la presse moi j'adorerais que
ce soit aujourd'hui au programme d'un
homme politique
je pense simplement que cette invitation
à l'indignation est une bonne chose
quand au bout du compte l'indignation ça
consisterait à voter martine aubry au
parti socialiste pour un deuxième tour
où elle serait candidate
je pense que ça fait un peu cheap comme
disait l'autre voilà alors on va
retrouver dans un instant nicolas tu
encaisses journaliste truong qui est
journaliste au monde
on va regarder avant ça le reportage de
tam tran huy qui est allé voir comment
fonctionne votre université populaire
qui vise à ouvrir à tous les portes de
la philosophie elle a été fondée à caen
mais elle a essaimé à paris le notam au
théâtre du rond point on regarde le
reportage de tam tran huy on se presse
dans le grand escalier du théâtre du
rond point
quelques minutes plus tard la salle est
comble le public attentif
aujourd'hui il ne vient pas assister à
un spectacle mais à une conférence
l'université populaire de caen pour la
deuxième saison vient jusqu'à paris
thème de cette année les monstres et
aujourd'hui le bourreau en littérature
mais d'abord une petite pique au chef de
l'état
faire plaisir nos amis nicolas je dirais
que le premier roman c'est bien la
princesse de clèves on a bien d'accord
mais romain classique puis les
références et analyse s'enchaînent on
passe des atrides de la tragédie grecque
au cyrielle killer moderne des films et
séries télé après un détour prolongé par
un succès littéraire récent celui des
bienveillantes prix goncourt 2006 et
bienveillante
honnêtement c'est vraiment un
sous-produit plus les mêmes lourd tous
les sens du terme
dans l'assistance la liberté de ton
marque les esprits
on peut elle fait une pique sur nicolas
sarkozy au début ne se serait pas permis
ça en course ça c'est clair mais dans ce
genre de conférence on a vraiment le
fond de sa pensée mais on est aussi
séduit par la diversité du cycle de
conférences on passe du cinéma
l'économie
ça nous donne des ouvertures là je
repars avec une liste de lecture
donc voilà c'est tout un travail à faire
après pour bénédicte lanes aux
professeurs dont le supérieur
l'exercice des université populaire de
caen est bien particulier il ya quelque
chose qui est toujours très frustrant
pour nous mes professeurs c'est que même
quand on travaille avec des étudiants
par exemple qui préparent des concours
on reste la parole d'autorité
alors qu'il m'est arrivé derrière
d'entrée en débat contradictoire avec le
public dans les universités populaires
et c'est ça aussi qui est intéressant
mais l'université populaire n'a pas pour
autant vocation à remplacer
l'enseignement institutionnels l'univers
si populaire c'est pas quelque chose qui
va contester universités classiques
c'est autre chose c'est d'ailleurs c'est
un espace un peu différemment et puis
c'est un espace citoyen pas de diplôme
pas d'évaluation ni de hiérarchie entre
le public et le conférencier mais une
réflexion teinté d'un esprit récréatif
un vrai moment de gai savoir
voilà on accueille nicolas truong qui
est conseillé de philosophie magazine
est responsable des pages débats au
quotidien le monde
alors vous aviez été nicolas truong à
l'origine d'une rencontre improbable au
moment de la présidentielle de 2007
entre notre invité est nicolas sarkozy
je voudrais vous demander tout d'abord
est ce que vous avez modifié votre
regard ou votre jugement sur nicolas
sarkozy depuis que vous l'avez rencontré
entre en 2007
non pas du tout je pense que c'est le
même en pire parce que
l'exercice du pouvoir de toute façon
qu'auront quiconque s'en emparer alors
quand ça corrompt quelqu'un qui est si
peu le sens de la république à
l'évidence on voit on voit comment ça
fonctionne alors il nous étonne toujours
parlé à l'époque de l' obsession
pathologique de jouir de la puissance
donnée par le pouvoir
c'est les mots que vous maintiendrez y
est suivra en prêt à bien sûr
non je pense que la république ça
suppose un sens un sens de l'état sens
de la communauté un sens d'autrui ce
sens je suppose
l'idée qu'il y aurait deux corps du roi
pour le dire comme kantorowicz et et on
se montre pas en short en train de faire
du vélo en train de suer de couvrir
rouge pas quoi enfin il ya cette façon
de mettre en avant l'un des deux
français vincent jay son image
oui mais enfin jeudi les deux corps du
roi le corps privé du roi normalement ne
montre pas où le montre peu et puis le
corde le véritable corps du roi dans la
république on le montre comme un
véritable corps du roi et ce corps du
roi est invisible
le corps du roi de la république on ne
le voit pas ou peu ou mal et en revanche
le corps du roi privé on ne voit que
trop nicolas triangle alors j'aurai
simplement ajouté que non pas au moins
gratifié si vous voulez nicolas sarkozy
d'avoir accepté après tout en pleine
campagne présidentielle nous avoir reçu
à deux reprises par ailleurs pour parler
au fond de philosophie alors que c'était
pas son domaine en tout cas d'idées de
politique avec un philosophe qui était
ouvertement critique et qui a emmené
michel onfray en l'occurrence et qui a
eu la main et la bonne idée de lui
offrir quatre livres notamment totem et
tabou de freud pas parce que au fond il
ya ce livre de freud malgré ton
reviendra peut-être sur le vote rituel
de freud mais c'était pour c'était pour
parler du du meurtre du père en
l'occurrence jacques chirac mais aussi
la propriété c'est le vol c'est l'emploi
vous aviez offert un livre de freud à
nicolas sarkozy avant de dézinguer freud
il fallait quand même le lire quatre
livres surveiller plaisir de michel
foucault évidemment puisque ça faisait
référence au ministère au ministre de
l'intérieur qu'il était à l'époque la
propriété c'est le vol et notamment et
de mode amant par le pronom produits
proudhon et puis
totem et tabou donc de l'antéchrist
données l'antéchrist denis dit puisque
au fond nicolas sarkozy avait parlé de
son rapport à la religion dans son livre
libre
alors à votre politique michel onfray
s'articule sur des bases pédagogiques
également vous avez donc fondé cette
université populaire en deux camps en
2002 et puis parce que vous refusez une
certaine manière d'enseigner la
philosophie très académique la même
manière que vous avez démissionné de
l'éducation nationale parce que vous ne
supportiez plus aussi la façon dont on
enseignait la philosophie au lycée
public en france alors est-ce que
première question est ce que depuis 2002
huit ans après au fond est-ce qu'il est
toujours nécessaire pour vous d'après
votre expérience de se hâter de rendre
la philosophie populaire puisque c'est
le mot de diderot que vous avez repris
pour monter cette université populaire
que jamais plus que jamais il me semble
que les lieux non institutionnelle et
bénédicte avez raison bénédicte ann doig
qui vous avez fait ce reportage avait
raison de dire que ce n'était pas fait
l'université populaire contre
l'université comme institution ça existe
et c'est très bien mais ça n'a rien à
voir
le lieu de l'université populaire est
effectivement un endroit de débat de
réflexion à caen il ya 18 professeurs
j'ai demandé à des amis
on le sait je n'aime pas beaucoup freud
j'ai demandé à une amie qui est
psychanalyste d'enseigner la
psychanalyse j'ai des amis qui sont des
libéraux je ne suis pas moins libérale
il met en scène y leurs options il ya du
débat il ya de la réflexion des gens qui
croient en dieu moi je n'y crois pas
donc j'ai voulu que ce soit un endroit
dans lequel les gens puissent entendre
des paroles libres discuter ces paroles
libres dans une dent dans un deuxième
temps puisqu'il ya un premier temps de
proposition d'un contenu le deuxième
temps qui est un commentaire du contenu
je pense que plus il y à des lieux comme
ceux là qui s'ouvre il ya une vingtaine
en france et quelques autres à
l'étranger
plus il ya des lieux comme cela plus on
fabrique des convivialités république et
est donc vous êtes ouvert à la diversité
aussi pédagogique en matière
d'université populaire parce que tard
anton amérique du sud où c'est très
développé on fait un peu plus appel ou
savoirs populaires qu'on se transmet au
fond presque sous forme de réseaux
d'échangé savoir la sont plutôt des
cours magistraux ouvert libre voire
libertaire pour certains d'entre eux
mais vous avez choisi plutôt cette
manière de faire c'est à dire au fond au
fond sur le modèle du court n est pas en
contradiction avec votre défense d'une
pédagogie libertaire un petit peu autres
que celles qu'on enseigne un peu au
lycée ou dans au sein de l'université
non je dis tout accord qui avait deux
temps dans l'université populaire et
vous auriez raison s'il n'y avait que le
premier temps à tant de propositions
d'un contenu en disant je viens cours ex
cathedra je propose une une réflexion en
cours sur je ne sais quoi je fais un
cours sur otto gross catalyst inventeur
du fraude au marxisme et puis à la
première heure je m'en vais avec mon
cartable et l affaire est réglée oui là
vous auriez raison ce serait
effectivement singer l'université ça n'a
aucun sens mais il ya une deuxième heure
qui est une occasion de débats d'accord
pas d'accord pourquoi a précisé expliqué
etc et je veux les deux je pense que la
première heure garde qui a de plus